gestern abend war es dann soweit das
konjunkturpaket steht so also man kann
sich das wie folgt vorstellen ich sage
es mal ein bisschen erlaubt 60
vorschläge eingereicht
frau merkel sitzt da wie so eine
wunschliste kreuz an zack zack zack so
und jetzt hat er sich entschieden ja
oder jetzt haben sie sich alle irgendwie
entschieden worum es jetzt geht was
sagst du diesen sinnvollen nicht
sinnvoll das ergebnis also stell dir vor
ein konjunkturpaket wird verabschiedet
und alle sind happy damit ist ja
wirklich es ist ja wahnsinn was in was
für seltsame zeiten wir uns gegenwärtig
befinden
und ich muss aber ganz ehrlich sagen
genau das passiert gerade also ich
glaube schon ist das eine historische
größenordnung hat dass da wirklich viele
punkte berücksichtigt worden sind wedelt
denkt an die sendungen die wir davor
hatten wo wir immer wieder auch über die
situation der mutter geredet haben über
das bildungsthema dass da jetzt auch
milliarden in die hand genommen werden
es ist sicherlich nicht perfekt aber
ausbesserung fähig aber ich finde das
ist schon sehr sehr guter stand und
jetzt geht es natürlich darum was wir
alle daraus machen und es geht letztlich
natürlich darum dass sozusagen auch
diese konsumflaute angekurbelt wird und
dafür muss geld in die hand genommen
werden damit dieses bruttosozialprodukt
auch 1 hat unsere eigenen kassen
und das ist dann natürlich die ein oder
andere gruppe gibt die sich vielleicht
nicht alle quad vertreten fühlt das
gehört dazu muss ich aber ja aber da
muss man herrn neuhaus wir schreiben
jetzt alles gespannt ob die kriterien
aber ich fühle mich einer gruppe die da
nicht ganz vertreten ist oder zumindest
300 euro pro kind für die familien das
empfinde ich wirklich als
bestechungsgeld oder als trostpflaster
bestechungsgeld in dem sinne so so jetzt
haben ja auch mal bewiesen dass wir ein
bisschen an euch denken hier sind 300
euro fertig aus
die drei kinder das sind 900 euro
monatlich einfach so kriegt ich glaube
dass tatsächlich nur ein gilt dass jeder
menge geld aber ich glaube dass allen
menschen sehr viel mehr geholfen wäre
wenn wir mal eine perspektive schaffen
würden wann die schulen wieder richtig
aufmachen wenn wir überhaupt eine
perspektive schaffen sind
wann die kitas wieder aufmachen wieder
alle familien mehr bringen als 300 euro
im übrigen die familien haben so
wahnsinnig gelitten in den letzten
monaten und als selbst da spreche ich
wieder aus einer position wo ich sagen
muss es geht noch ich bin nur diejenige
die durchdreht und er denkt ich bin alle
kinder und ich bin keine lehrer ich kann
das hier nicht mehr ich werfe das
handtuch
aber es gibt ja viel viel
krasse fälle als irgendwie den alltag
den ich beschreibe dort sind 300 euro
natürlich eine menge geld aber es wäre
den kindern sehr viel mehr geholfen wenn
sie in die kita zurück könnten wo sie
ihre freunde sehen wo sie in einem
sozialen sicheren umfeld sind wo sie ihr
essen bekommen und auch dazu wieder kein
wort 300 euro bestechungsgeld damit hat
wir gesehen wie bei familie haben an
euch gedacht fertig aus das ist ja ein
bisschen anders gewesen also es würde ja
zum beispiel auch mehrere milliarden
dafür die hand genommen insbesondere
eben auch für diesen kita und auch die
schul und bildungsbereich genau und
natürlich auch bei eigener 3 wichtiger
ist die frage aber trotzdem
beispielsweise wieder ganz konkret die
300 euro
wie ist das für hartz4 empfänger mit den
kindern wird es angerechnet wird es
nicht angerechnet es ist ja eine
gerechtigkeitsfrage die sich wieder
stellt und natürlich haben die die am
existenzminimum leben wieder die sorge
und angst dass sie haben ende wieder
alles tragen müssen und da würde ich
sagen würde ich gerne noch das thema
erweitern um beispielsweise starbucks
amazon das nur zu sagen nur die leute
von den steuersenkungen profitieren die
auch hier die steuern zahlen
und dass da natürlich natürlich mit
argusaugen jetzt drauf geguckt werden
muss das ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe
aber ich finde das eine chance jetzt
dass die wirtschaft angekurbelt ist ich
meine es ist bestimmt nicht einfach 1000
leute strömen
wer will dass jedem gerecht zu werden
ist nicht so einfach nicht
und ich finde aber es ist ein guter
anfang das dass es weitergeht und wir
haben erleben dass ihr alle zum ersten
mal so eine idee und ja ich finde es
eigentlich ganz gute lösung und leute
die haben gerade über den populisten
geredet ich bin froh dass ich im moment
nicht von populisten durch die krise
regiert werde und dass zuversicht
vermittelt wird und dazu gehört auch
dieses zukunftshoffnung stuck geht
[Musik]